so with that i see brook is here let me
just play her music really quickly
because
people work hard to get their songs
all right taken away bro thank you
awesome thank you so much jared sorry
for the delay um we had a whole keynote
with some
animations and uh
we couldn't share it so we're gonna do
this powerpoint uh and do it live but
hi thanks um my name is brooke madibongo
i
am the director of legal analytics and
quantitative research
at the aclu so for folks who don't know
what the aclu is
we're an organization that uses
primarily litigation and advocacy to
enhance and promote civil rights and
civil liberties
in the us and a big area of work for us
is uh improving the rights of folks who
are uh
involved in the criminal uh legal system
and so
um part of my work on the analytics team
is to support the work of our of our
advocates
and lawyers so i'm going to talk today
about a project we did to model
the spread of covet 19 in jails um
we're going to talk about why we're
focusing on jails in particular
but those some of these sort of
takeaways do extend to
prisons and immigration detention
centers other detention facilities
we're going to talk about modeling a
single jail outbreak and then the the
challenges of scaling that up
in r and then talk about sort of the
takeaways
so first um why focus on jails i think
we can kind of start from where we are
now
um and what we know about what's going
on in
in jails and prisons right now 10 of the
largest 10
clova 19 hot spots in the us are in
jails or prisons
i think something like between two
thirds and three-fourths of
uh the hundred biggest outbreaks are in
jails and prisons these are
um real hotbeds for uh for spread
um and this has already been we did this
work back in
uh april and and unfortunately we're
seeing a lot of the
the adverse outcomes that we anticipated
there out in these systems
um and there there are a lot of reasons
why
this is the case um jail and prison and
immigration detention centers are
um super overcrowded very frequently
um the sanitation is is really a
challenge in these systems
there's poor ventilation there's sort of
dilapidated conditions
um people who are incarcerated are often
required to
provide their own to purchase their own
hygiene materials
at you know on the sort of inhumane
wages that they're they're given for
working in in these person systems so
um it's it's really a volcano ready to
explode
um so back in march and april activists
were already sounding the alarm around
this and we were lucky enough to work
with um three academics uh eric lofgren
christian loom
uh and nina peppermint along with my
colleague aaron horowitz at the aclu
to build an epidemiological model
of uh what would happen to the spread in
these systems
so first i want to talk about modeling
that one outbreak um
a little primer for folks who aren't
familiar um
with epidemiological models although
many more of us
are than used to be in the past
unfortunately because of what's going on
right now essentially in a compartmental
epidemiological model you move from
being
susceptible to a particular infection to
being exposed
to being infectious and able to spread
it to others and then
uh if you do not die from that infection
you are
recovered and so we can use a system of
differential equations to
um model sort of the transmission of a
disease through a population
this is what that looks like in math if
folks are are sort of mappy
this can be a little bit intimidating
but basically it's just saying that the
rate of transition between these two
these states is a function of some of
the natural disease parameters
so um with covid there are there are
sort of
average ranges that you spend in the uh
pre-infectious period the e compartment
the exposed compartment
and the infectious compartment for
example and it's also a function of
um the con effect of contact between
individuals who are infectious and who
are susceptible so
that itself is a function of both
natural history
parameters of the disease but also
things like how often
people are coming into effective contact
so this is what a really really basic
compartmental model looks like
in r we use the desolve package and
it's essentially just putting this up
here into code um
it's pretty straightforward this is a
really simplistic version of the model
and i don't want to spend too much time
talking
um about this i want to talk about the
challenges of scaling that up
um but uh this is
so so we're going through pictures math
and
code um this is the picture of what our
model looks like so not only are you
moving through
sei and r compartments but you can also
move from the community
through to booking and processing um
through the jail system
and and we parameterized this using real
values from
allegheny county the jail system which
published really um
really complete thorough sort of
estimates of how many people are being
arrested every day how many of those
people are being booked into jail
how many people in jail have a trial on
any given day
etc um just briefly that's what that
looks like in
math in our paper it's very complicated
but it's not very complex it's
straightforward as long as you can get
all of the parameters right
and again this is what this looks like
in code um
it's a lot but um it's again
straightforward once you can get
um and which is to say once you can
wrangle a bunch of academics to do all
the hard stuff for you
um this is what the baseline looks like
if we if we do nothing
the disease spreads through
the jail at a given at a much higher
rate than than through the community and
that's because
people in jails are coming into
effective contact at much higher
frequency than people who are
just in the in a community
um so essentially the the first step of
this was taking
um parameterizing that model to one
particular system
um running all of our code uh that was
the focus of the paper
and then we wanted to see sort of what
is the national scale
of um what is the impact at a national
level
if this outbreak happens in every jail
um and so we looked at every single jail
with a jail population of over
um 100 people uh which accounts for
around
90 of the population of the us um live
in a county with one of these jails
um and used a lot of open data that that
is made available to to parameterize
these outbreaks so i'm going to talk
about four challenges
of scaling up a single model in one
community to
essentially the nation so challenge one
we had all this great information from
allegheny county about the rates of
movement from jail to court the rates of
um
how frequently people are arrested the
average length of detention
um the size of the incarcerated
population the size of the jail staff
um who are are moving through these
systems um but we wanted to go from from
that one place to
um localizing this in various counties
and so that involves
um some parameters that are that are
natural disease history parameters of
cova-19
um and some sort of custom uh
pieces of information from from
different places um and this
was only possible because of open data
sets
that we were able to use from largely
from the vera institute
we used again a lot of information
specific to allegheny county we used
some census of jails data from the
bureau of justice statistics
um we used new york times data to
understand you know how far along
in the communities were each of these
infections at the time that we were
modeling them
and so that was
only this research was only possible
because of open public data we talked
earlier about
um uh about the importance of
of open data and also open science in
this process so that was
a huge one for us the second challenge
was
parallelizing this model so um
straightforward enough to run a
differential to solve a set of
differential equations in one place
um we looked at six different scenarios
um
and and various assumptions in each
scenario um and this is manageable but
then we ran that across
um over 1200 jurisdictions
and had um hourly time points for each
so
that ended up to be a lot of simulations
and so
the solution to that challenge um
thankfully
was very straightforward in our because
of the future and fur packages the
latter of which i'm
now learning i think today is is
launching some big updates
um but this allowed us to essentially
write the code the same way we would
have if we're just doing um
building one model and um split it
across
96 cores again using
um some ec2 instances that we
that we spun up so that's what this is
what this looks like
um if if folks are users of the per
package
um we mapped some functions over
a list of different scenarios um and
parameterize that with a certain
sort of like starting conditions based
on that locality certain parameters and
ran it for
for a given number of days and
were able to do the same thing using fur
so the syntax is really similar
this is a different function obviously
but that allowed us to to get this done
in
less than months which is what it might
have taken otherwise um the third thing
i wanted to talk about was
was in testing um this is sort of
lessons learned from this process
uh and one of the lessons that we
learned in scaling up was that
we weren't going to be able to look at
pictures to to test so
when we were building our original model
um
we diagnosed bugs in our code based on
just looking at output so
there was a period of time where we were
trying to to troubleshoot this one thing
that was happening where
no matter which version that we no
matter which simulation that we were
using and which scenario
we were looking at we were getting just
people in the population falling off
completely vanishing from from all the
compartments and this is not
because people are dying from the
disease because those people remain in
the compartments
this is just people disappearing uh
because one of our terms wasn't paired
so
we were able to test visually when we're
modeling just one uh
outbreak but that's not really feasible
when we have 20
000 models um and so we were lucky
enough at the aclu to be able to bring
in our data or
data engineering team um i think
that's my recommendation strongly but
that's not available to everyone and so
um you can definitely bring in data
engineering best practices
one of which is is testing and making
sure that um
you're building in your assumptions and
failing pretty loudly when
your code is not meeting your
assumptions
um challenge number four that i wanted
to talk about that i think has been
mentioned in
in this kind of setting frequently um is
that when you're scaling up often we
didn't have data for
specific localities so one thing that we
um
one issue that we ran into when we were
trying to
um to scale up and and seeing some weird
outputs is that we had forgotten to set
our seed
um and we're getting different versions
across multiple different
um outputs and so this is again let me
join the chorus of folks to remind you
to set your seed
um especially if you're in this is a
really simple imputation to
um estimate the the size of the staff
population in
jail systems where we didn't know the
size of the staff population
um so i want to talk about some of the
scenarios that we ran and some of the
results and i'm moving really quickly
because this is
a ton of um stuff but i'll i'll make
these slides
available um and our paper is also
available publicly as well so
um we wanted to look at three main
interventions
um to potentially reduce the impact of
kova 19
in jails um we looked at reducing intake
um
so reducing arrests changing some
arrests to
um citations for example and just
reducing the number of the number of
arrests that are happening in the
community
um we looked at reducing arrests and
increasing the release
the speed of release for individuals
particularly in this case for medically
vulnerable individuals
and the aclu has taken a bunch of
lawsuits arguing that essentially
detaining people who are
are medically vulnerable in these
situations is a violation of their human
rights it puts them at too great over
risk
and finally we looked at sort of a
blanket um
collection of actions that we could take
within the jails for the people who do
remain
um as much as we would like it it's not
feasible right now
uh for us to be living in a jail-free
world
um and so so what can we do to
actually protect the people who are who
are still um behind bars
uh and essentially what we found is the
best way to
reduce transmission and to reduce
infections hospitalizations and deaths
in both
the jail and in the community is to
reduce arrest and bookings as much as
possible don't bring into people into
the system
because when you bring people into jail
systems in particular which have very
low rates
are very low average lengths of
detention um and in which people are
often cycling back
into the community you're not only
infecting those people
and and harming the people who are
incarcerated but you're also
um seeding that infection in the broader
community and really exaggerating the
problem so that was
that was the biggest thing that we could
do um we also found that
increasing the speed of releasing people
especially if you can act quickly and
early in the outbreak
um before it spreads throughout the jail
ideally um
then that really reduces cases and
deaths uh in the jails in the
communities especially
for medically vulnerable people so i
know these graphs are hard to read when
we're moving so quickly but um
in this middle row we're looking at
infections hospitalizations and deaths
of incarcerated people and and we see
um a real big jump in
decrease in deaths when we release
medically
vulnerable people from jail as quickly
as we can
and finally uh it's definitely necessary
to to do the
the collection of things that we know
are um
we're supposed to do to prevent the
spread of coca-19 in the community we
have to be able to make those available
in jails as well we have to give people
masks we have to uh improve sanitation
and hygiene we have to
um reduce the population population so
that socially distancing is even
possible
um and that's necessary but it's not
enough to stop transit
transmission um
so i want to talk about sort of like
when we run these 1200 models and
aggregate that together
and make some pretty uh sort of like
reasonable assumptions
about death rate about hospitalization
rates
based on on where we were in march and
the information that was
available at the time um we find that
across the board reducing arrests saves
lives it saves
tons of lives in the jails but it also
saves
hundreds of or tens of thousands of
lives in the community um
this isn't just an intervention it's
it's a very important intervention for
people who are incarcerated but it's not
just for them it's for
the for everybody and this is again an
example of when we
do the right thing by people who are
just involved and
involved in the criminal legal system uh
it it helps all of us
and this finding has been sort of
corroborated by two
additional studies one in chicago and
one in milwaukee
that essentially find that jail
community cycling is a big predictor of
cases of coronavirus
um in chicago they found that this was a
bigger predictor than
race a bigger predictor than poverty
than many of the other
risk factors that we know contribute to
covert 19 spread
that bringing people into the jail
system often um
not releasing them only because they
can't pay bail um
is is a huge risk factor uh
people maybe not working in this space
may not know that the majority of people
who are in jail
uh are detained pre-trial they haven't
been convicted yet
um and a majority of those people are
only in jail because they can't pay
can't afford their bail or bond right um
and so
the system doesn't have to be that way
we don't have to use cash bail
um these are these are interventions
that we can take right now
and this is important because uh for for
many reasons one because people's lives
are at risk
um but it also exacerbates the racial
disparities present in coven 19 cases
and deaths
so nationwide people black people are
dying at 2.5 times the rate of white
people
and it's even greater i think when you
look at age stratified rates
and that's for many reasons but a lot of
those get back to the systemic
disparities
so uh the graph that you're seeing on
the left is showing that
um black people are a disproportionate
number of the stops and searches
in um in washington dc and
we see that uh not only stops uh are
disproportionately of of black people
but that stops that don't lead to
anything so essentially useless stops
right um
stops that that probably are um
ones that that white people wouldn't be
stopped for um
are are even more disparate right and
and a lot of
um evidence is sort of corroborates this
like we know that there are racial
disparities at every
um every sort of phase of the system
and so in the minute that i have left i
want to talk about um
where how this is used um as of mid-july
of this year we'd filed over 161 legal
actions
related to covet 1969 in jails and
prisons
32 of these are class actions 51 in
immigration detention
and we've also used this in successful
advocacy with
our partners to release over 48 000
people from
from detention whether that's jail
prison or immigration detention so
really the strength of this work is only
useful if our advocates can take it and
run with it and these are the people
doing the real
work on the ground frankly um but i
wanted to give this this one example of
how
statistics and data science can be used
to um to sort of
support uh advocacy and and litigation
so um thanks very much sorry for my
technical difficulties um
the report is available on the aclu
website
um these slides are up on my github and
then i'm
on twitter if you want to talk about it
so thanks very much
you